WHAT OF WE DO LIKE
A LITTLE SCRIMMAGE?
ADAM, YOU BE THE FIREE...
- THAT DOESN'T MAKE MUCH SENSE,
KINDA THE TOP GUN.
- AND I WILL BE
THE FIRER, OKAY.
AND NO MATTER WHAT THIS GUY SAYS
OR THROWS MY WAY, YOU KNOW,
I'LL JUST POWER THROUGH
AND I'LL FIRE THE GUY, OKAY?
IT'S REAL EASY.
ARE YOU READY?
- I'M READY.
- OKAY. LET'S GET TO IT.
ADAM, I'M SORRY TO SAY THIS,
BUT WE GOT TO LET YOU GO, BUD.
- YOU'RE FIRING ME?
I WORK HERE FOR 60 YEARS
BUILDING THIS COMPANY
FROM THE GROUND UP,
AND YOU FIRING ME?
- SORRY, DUDE.
- I AIN'T GOING OUT
LIKE NO BITCH, YOU BITCH.
- ANDERS, YOU HEARD ANYTHING?
I CAN'T LOSE MY JOB,
YOU UNDERSTAND?
I AIN'T GOING BACK
TO SUBSTITUTE TEACHING.
- MONTEZ, MY EYES
ARE BURNING RIGHT NOW.
COME ON.
- YOU KIDS GOT NO SHAME,
NO DECENCY.
THANKS FOR THIS APRON, MAN.
- YOU GOT A .44 MAGNUM
POINTED AT YOUR HEAD.
WHAT THE [bleep]
ARE YOU DOING?
YOU FIRE ME, I'LL KILL YOU
AND EVERYBODY IN HERE.
- OH, DO WHAT HE SAYS, BLAKE.
- YOU REALLY THINK
I'M THAT STUPID?
- WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
- CHECK THE GUN, HOTSHOT.
- VERY CLEVER.
VERY CLEVER.
YOU TAKE THE BULLETS
OUT OF MY GUN.
- YEAH.
- BUT LET'S SEE IF YOU CAN
TAKE THE BULLETS
OUT OF THIS BUTTERFLY KNIFE.
- JILLIAN, GO AHEAD AND GIVE
THIS GUY A CIGARETTE,
'CAUSE I'M ABOUT
TO LIGHT HIM UP.
- ARE THOSE SUNGLASSES?
- YEAH, SUNGLASSES.
- COOL.
- FOR MY FLAMETHROWER.
- NO, NO.
- YOU'RE FIRED.
- NO!
- YOU'RE SO FIRED.
- [screaming]
- OOH! OOH! OOH!
- [still screaming]
- AND HE'S FIRED.
- AND I'M FIRED.
- THAT WAS VERY INFORMATIVE.
- THANK YOU.